leider bringen ich heute ein thema die
nicht so schön ist und es gibt nicht
viel zu lachen leider mussten wir wieder
over muslimischen antisemitismus
sprechen gestern abend in hagen eine
lade wo aus unterschiedlichen
geheimdienste die informationen gekommen
sind dass eine geplante anschlag auf die
synagoge am höchsten feiertag der
jüdische gemeinde am jom kippur wo
menschen die auch nicht so religiös sind
in der synagoge gehen genau wie vor zwei
jahren in halle wurde ein anschlag
geplant gott sei dank wurde ist dieses
mal
veraltet und kam nicht dazu
im gewahrsam ist drei menschen einer
davon eine 16-jährige aus syrien und
hier müssen wir wieder über islamische
und islamistische antisemitismus
sprechen über kopenhagen ober brüssel
oder paris über halle also halle war es
natürlich rechtsradikalismus aber die
gefährdung der jüdische gemeinden in
deutschland in europa steigt permanent
hoch und menschen überlegen und sie in
deutschland als juden sicher leben
konnten sie denken an
auswanderung richtung israel wir mussten
mal darüber nachdenken menschen in
europa menschen in deutschland wie hier
geboren aufgewachsen
denken an nach israel zu gehen um da in
sicherheit zu leben und was tun wir wir
haben ja nicht zum ersten mal eine
diskussion über antisemitismus ich
erinnere an mai 2021 mit unglaublichen
aggressiven demonstrationen gegen den
krieg in gaza ich erinnern eher an
diskussionen über importierte
antisemitismus wir verlieren uns immer
wieder in begrifflichkeiten stadt dass
wir handeln und handeln bedeutet wir
müssen endlich begreifen wir haben ein
problem und ja
antisemitismus herkunft übergreifend
antisemitismus wendet man erreicht im
links in der mitte der gesellschaft aber
es gibt auch muslimische antisemitismus
und ihn zu ignorieren helft uns in diese
gesellschaft nicht damit umzugehen
weniger mahnwachen und viel mehr handeln
wird aber ist das nicht verrückt wir
kennen dieses phänomen des muslimischen
antisemitismus schon seit jahren und sie
halten hier in flammen dann vollkommen
richtigen appellen ich glaube sie müssen
ihn nach halten aber warum sprechen wenn
ich offen über das thema ist das angst
vor rassismus vorwürfen ist dass
irgendeine linke rote rose rosarote
brille die wir nicht abziehen wollen
warum ist das überhaupt noch thema warum
muss man daran erinnern dass es das gibt
der die angst vor rassismus vorwerfen es
gibt ganz oft betroffene aussagen von
von linken oder von grünen politikern
zum thema antisemitismus in deutschland
in dem das wort islam islamismus nicht
vorkommt wo quasi das bild erweckt wird
als sei der einzige antisemitismus mit
dem es in deutschland immer noch zu tun
haben der alte oder der neue nazi und
die gibt es ja auch immer noch aber in
der tat wenn man mit juden spricht wenn
sie durch unsere stadtviertel gerade
auch hier in berlin gehen dann ist das
nicht primäres problem und das wird
negiert sowie auch andere probleme der
muslimischen community regiert werden
weil es nicht nicht nicht nicht hoch
genug ist diese probleme zu benennen die
angst vor dem rassismusvorwurf ja
sicherlich eine die die die jeder gerade
in die unserer tochtergesellschaft im
kopf haben muss nicht denn ein falsches
wort schön wenn wir alle hier von der
einen oder anderen seite geschlachtet
und ich glaube jeder politiker jede
politikerin hat sowas auch im kopf
deswegen finde ich sehr angenehm wenn
wir da mal klare meinungen und
meinungsbekundungen hören wir von hin
aber
die die keiner ich meine wer ich bin
heute denke alle mit ihnen wein als
antisemitismus ist was furchtbares geht
nicht in deutschland schon gar nicht und
kein israeli oder kein mensch jüdischen
glaubens dafür in irgendeiner weise das
gefühl haben nicht willkommen zu sein
darf nicht das gefühl haben verfolgt zu
werden oder wenn er verfolgt wird muss
er sicher sein dass er geschützt wird
wie das offenkundig ja heute auch gott
sei dank des hinweises offenbar eines
ausländischen ein dienstes jahr der fall
war oder nachrichten sagt man ja und
jetzt gehört es auch dazu und ich weiß
jetzt dass ist nicht en vogue schon gar
nicht zu sagen bei diesem 16 jährigen
hat man bisher noch nichts gefunden
keine bombe kein sprengsatz nix
es gibt den hinweis dass er sich
irgendwo im netz da möglicherweise
kundig gemacht wie man bomben baut und
dass er vorhatte verschlingen wäre an
yom kippur diesen an stark zu machen das
ist auch mit keiner silbe in irgendeiner
weise zu rechtfertigen oder zu
verteidigen das schlimme ist aber wenn
man so ein argument einbringt in diese
diskussion gehört man genauso zu den
verharmlosen zu den gleich machen und zu
denjenigen die sagen zurecht mutmaßlich
und ich werde der erste der sich freut
wenn diesen anschlag nicht geplant wäre
weil die nach die die langfristige
folgen von so einen geplanten anschlag
auch wenn er nicht durchgeführt wird die
menschen vor ort das spüren die menschen
nach 23 jahren deshalb bin ich absolut
bei ihnen ich suche auch nicht nach
probleme mir geht es nicht darum zu
feiern das endlich ich in meine
selektive wahrnehmung irgendwie
bestätigt bekommen darum geht es nicht
das tut auch die andere seite das blut
auch die rechten man sieht es ja auf
twitter man sucht um zu wissen welche
herkunft ein attentäter hat um zu wissen
ob er in für eine ideologie gestärkt
wird oder nicht trotzdem wir haben hier
ein problem wo ich das gefühl habe nicht
nur unsere politiker auch unsere medien
haben schwierigkeiten das anzusprechen
haben schwierigkeiten das zu benennen
und vor allem zu handeln ich bin seit 16
jahren in deutschland ich habe so viele
debatten sie werden zwischen 2014 mit
dem youtube com heraus und kämpft allein
2017 mit der mit der senat mit der
botschaft von tel aviv der umzug der
amerikanischen botschaft und täler von
tel aviv nach jerusalem
2021 ist passiert immer wieder aber und
dann vergessen wie leicht öffentlich
nicht mehr als ahmad war es ein problem
ist damit was passiert als ich
bundesfamilienministerin war war ich
habe für solche projekte zustände gehen
kann
das mit familienministerium und ehrlich
gesagt man kann dort nur
rassistischen antisemitismus na also die
klassische deutsche form der der
islamistische antisemitismus gab es
nicht viel und dann hab ich mittel habe
ich generiert und habe neue projekte
aufgelegt aber es ist unglaublich schwer
da seriöse träger zu finden der wirklich
mit dem geld auch eine vernünftige
abmahnung wir wollen hingegen
antisemitismus stichtag wirklich ist
auch in meine arbeit dass viele
antisemitismus projekte und dann geht
man da und erzählt die kinder dass juden
und muslime gleich sind ich will
schwierig leute zu finden die gegen
antisemitismus kämpfen anschneiden es
ist schwierig
ja aber warum im integrations und
präventions- landschaft ist es so dass
viele linke
aktiven das muss ich in aller
deutlichkeit sagen und die haben keine
interesse aber nicht
entsprechen und man nicht was ich muss
machen sie lieber und an und muslimische
antisemitismus das ist so ein bisschen
schwierig das können wir nicht und da
redet man oder bleibt man ob die
oberfläche aber redet nicht über die
tatsächlichen probleme unser studio sein
land berlin hat dass das als anti
muslime stand ausgelegt unsere studios
in berlin kreuzberg einmal in die runde
gefragt ist judenhass hier drüben wenige
hundert meter wenige kilometer entfernt
in den schulen mehrheitsfähig
das sind großes wort habe ich mir kein
urteil zu was
ich glaube wenn es um israel geht
dass viele menschen eine einseitige
betrachtung dieses landes haben und
negative einstellungen zu israel haben
was dazu führen konnte dass man
antisemitische einstellung entwickelt
und noch etwas das ist nicht nur unter
migranten das ist unter jugendlicher man
darf nicht vergessen welche position
frei die für future im mai 2021
gezeigt haben und das ist der nährboden
für anti-israelische
antisemitismus nähe des freibades
featurettes in einen topf geworfen wird
doch das mache ich bewusstsein an das
machen sie umgaben bisschen
aufmerksamkeit ich zitiere das nein ist
sascha lobo der nicht jetzt hier gut ja
meine ecke gehört der gestern oder
vorgestern sagte anti rassismus ist
nichts wert wenn ihr
antisemitismus betreibt in kauf nimmt
oder verharmlost und freude für future
hat eine position im mai 2021 zu gaza
krieg der viele jugendliche in ihre
antisemitische einstellungen bestätigt
hat und das muss thematisiert werden
müssen wie fühlt sich ein bisschen weit
noch mal sagen was das für eine position
war und ob das nicht im apartheid-staat
da irgendwie vielmehr sei es war ein
reiner software international also die
internationale dachorganisation die sich
wie ich sagen würde massiv antisemitisch
geäußert hat die haben von märtyrern
gesprochen und damit hamas-terroristen
gemeint die deutsche organisation hat
sich davon distanziert wurde davon auch
eine verendet das interessante ist ja
sind halt weiterhin mitglied man also
man kann halt nicht sagen antisemitismus
das ist für uns die absolute rote linie
aber wenn die dachorganisation sich mit
hamas touristen solidarisiert dann sagen
wir finden das dorf aber die nächsten
streik organisieren geht es darum dass
man nicht jeden aktivisten auch nicht
unterschieden und da mal so da finde ich
überschreiten sie immer rote linien und
das macht sie auch in gewisser weise
unglaubwürdig weil es klingt so als
würden sie jeden aktivisten von freddie
for future ein eintopf mit einigen
rollen nämlich was sie musste den
letzten mal aber das haben sie beim plan
mache ich es mache es war auch ich und
beweglich zu ihrem
realen israel nein es geht nicht es muss
absolut aber ich finde gerne richtung
dieses protein lassen sie uns nicht
gegen den thw wir haben mir was vor
umgeworfen lassen sie mich bitte
ausreden ich bin nicht mit der politik
israel einverstanden aber ich arbeite
vor ort ich bin in gefängnissen in
schulen ich bin unterwegs tagtäglich mit
jugendlicher 2 und welche aussagen und
welche aussagen wie bei juve jugendliche
an koch einfach ich habe freude future
gesagt und nicht jede aktivist rida
future aber sie haben einmal verstanden
natürlich gibt es unterschiedliche
menschen unter jugendlichen die sich so
klima interessieren aber diese linke
ideologie die teilweise mit den
underdogs palästina immer
unreflektiert
solidarisiert ohne die israelische seite
sehen zu wollen ist ein nährboden
vorantasten diese freiheit einheimischen
als überparteiliche bewegung die
sicherlich gespeist wird aus
unterschiedlichen gruppen und deswegen
wäre ich mich wo ich später mitglied bin
auch unterschiedliche schwerpunkte aber
in meiner politischen ausrichtung diese
diese organisation gleich eine linke
gruppe darauf können wir uns
wahrscheinlich einigen also weitgehend
ich will jetzt nicht ist für sie aber
ist eine linke gruppe und es gibt auch
einen linken antisemitismus sind
es gibt auch einen rechten
antisemitismus es gibt einen
islamistischen antisemit antisemitismus
zwischen den verschiedenen aber du
würdest sagen jetzt keine linke gruppe
freies for future eine analyse über
überparteiliche eine eine aus dem aus
dem bewusstsein genährte etwas fürs
klima tun zu müssen die welt retten
das ist
ja es ist ich belaufe da nicht mit aber
ich finde man muss es tatsächlich so
sehen wie es ist anliegen kann ein
überparteiliches sagen das doch mal so
aber ich würde mal sagen sowie freies
für futures buchstabiert hat es ganz
starke antikapitalistische und teilweise
auch antidemokratische ziehen sobald ist
schon antikapitalismus ich will und ich
will noch eines wissen weil wir
diskutieren über antisemitismus ich
behaupte einmal bela wenn du noch in
seiner alten funktion regierungssprecher
gewesen wäre ist am heutigen tag es
kommt der fall hagen auf den tisch der
verliest eine erklärung verurteilt das
ganze und dann weg mit dem zettel und
der fall ist erledigt ist er nicht weil
es gremien gibt über die da sehr
intensiv
darüber geredet wird jetzt ein bisschen
weit führen die zu benennen aber ist
sicherlich nicht damit
bereinigt oder erledigt ich werde viel
gerät in diesem land zu viel das denke
ich auch beim thema antisemitismus und
den kern packen wir irgendwie noch nicht
an wir wissen gar nicht wie wir mit 16
jährigen umgehen sollen und wollen die
in der schule sitzen und menschen hassen
weil sie juden sind
[Musik]